اعلنت روسيا ان طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه
هاجمت عددا من مقاطعاتها بينها العاصمه
موسكو التي علقت حركه الطيران مؤقتا في
اثنين من مطاراتها بسبب تلك الهجمات كان
ذاك خبر حلقه ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
ما دلاله تكثيف اوكرانيا هجماتها
بالطائرات المسيره على مقاطعات عده في
روسيا وما حدود التزام الغرب بتسليم
اوكرانيا مقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه وكيف
نقرا مستقبل الحرب في اوكرانيا
وانعكاساتها على المشهد الدولي
تتسبب بالكثير من الاضرار ولا توقعوا
الكثير من الخسائر مقارنه
بالهجمات الصاروخيه والسيارات الروسيه هذه
هجمات اوكرانيه لا تقارن حقيقه لكنها
بمثابه تذكير للشعب الروسي بان هناك حرب
مستعره ورغم كل ما يسمعونها في وسائل
الاعلام هناك حرب ستاتي اليه وستقالهم نحن
ننظر لهذه الاوضاع بجديه
والاستنتاجات التي لدينا في روسيا هي اننا
علينا ان نطور قدرتنا في الدفاع الجوي
الالكتروني ان الهجمات بالمسيرات حتى وان
كانت غير قويه ومؤثره ولكن الاوضاع بحد
ذاتها جاده وفي هذا الضوء هذه الوسائل
لاسقاط هذه المسيرات هي ذات ولكن يجب ان
نفهم جيدا ان هذا جزء من الحرب الاعلاميه
الاوكرانيه هناك جمله من الاسباب اول هذه
الاسباب القيود والخطوط الحمراء المفروضه
على توظيف السلاح الغربي داخل الجغرافيا
الروسيه وبالتالي كان البديل ان يتم
استخدام مقاربه من انتاج اوكران هناك
ضائقه في ومعاناه بنقص الذخائر البعد
البعد الثالث دائره الحرب بالنسبه لروسيا
عمليه عسكريه خاصه ضمن شرق اوكرانيا
بينما ما يجري هو حاله حرب بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وعليها ان تنقل الحرب الى ارض
الخصر
[موسيقى]
الامريكيون الذين هم بالطبع صانعوا هذه
الطائرات قد اعطوا موافقتهم لهولندا
والدنمارك لتسليمه الطائرات الى
الاوكرانيين وانا واثق من نفس الموافقه
ستعطى لبلدان الاخرى هذا هو الامر المهم
لاننا حتى اللحظه لم نحصل على الموافقه
الرسميه للامريكيين وهو امر ضروري لكي
تنظر الامور قدما متى نتوقع وصول الطائرات
الكل يرمي او يميل الى الاعتقاد بان لن
يكون ذلك قبل نهايه هذا العام
الامريكيون يفضلون القيامه بذلك عن طريق
الحلفاء الاوروبيين هناك بعض قلق في
واشنطن حول تقديم واشنطن هذه الطائرات
بشكل مباشر لان الحسابات الامريكيه
الى هذا الحذر لكن ربما بعد اشهر قد يغير
الامريكيين موقفهم اولا ان الموقف الروسي
في هذا النزاع لن يتغير لدى روسيا اهدافها
ومصالحها التي تريد ان تحققها في اوكرانيا
ولن تتغير اما بالنسبه للاف سته عشر
المقاتلات الامريكيه اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين
يضعون الكثير من الامال على هذه المقاتلات
لماذا في العام الماضي كان الاوكرانيين
يقول نفس الشيء عن الهايمرز او الجبلين
وكانوا يقولوا ان الدبابات سوف تساعدهم في
الهجمات المضاده ولكننا نرى الان ان كل
هذه
المعدات هي هدف مشروع وشرعي للجيش الروسي
وفي هذا المعنى اعتقد ان مصير الاف 16
سيكون نفس مصير الفرد ومختلف الاسلحه التي
تاتي من الدول الغربيه ميسان القوى من حيث
القوه الجويه ما بين الجانب الروسي
والاوكراني الفتره الحاليه هي تقريبا تسعه
الى واحد 950 او 9 الى 970 طائره مقاتله
ومعترضه روسيه مقابل 176 طائره اوكرانيا
الان ما هو عدد هذه الطائرات التي التي
يتوقع وصوله الان تم الحديث عن 42 طائره
كدفعه اولى من دوله واحده وهناك دفعات يجب
ان لا يقل عدد الطائرات اف 16 التي
تتسلمها
اوكرانيا ويكون لديها اطقم من الطيارين
والفنيين ومنظومات الصيانه والبنيه
التحتيه بصوره متكامله وجاهزه وفاعله عن
100 طائره اذا توفر هذا الرقم ستحدث فرقا
نعم لن تستخدم في العمق الروسي لكن ستحقق
جزئيا التفوق الجوي المحلي ستحجم من السيط
الجويه للطيران الروسي ولمنظومه الصواريخ
الروسيه اعتقد اننا راينا استمرارا في رفع
مستوى تقديمي المعدات الى اوكرانيا من
الغرب منذ العام الماضي الاف سته عشر سوف
تعطي درجه اعلى في سلم رفع الكفاءات هذا
ايضا لكن متى والى اي مدى نستمر لا ادري
هذا يفتح تساؤلات كثيره فيما يتعلق
بالاسلحه
حديث عن الاهداف التي وضعناها وهو تامين
الامن الروسي على الحدود مع اوكرانيا ومنع
توسيع النيتو
وروسيا لم تخطئ في حساباتها ان روسيا تقوم
بالاندماج مع هذه الظروف الجديده
والامكانيات الاوكرانيه تغيرت فعلا ولكننا
نفهم ان الجيش
الاوكراني هو معتمد تماما من التمويل
والمساعدات العسكريه من الدول الاوروبيه
والولايات المتحده لذلك ما دام هناك رغبه
بان يقوموا بضرر ضد روسيا من قبل الدول
الاوروبيه سوف نستمر باعمالنا